je voudrais charlotte valandrey vous
présenter aux spectateurs car on ne se
rend pas compte dans cette scène très
légère qu'on vient de voir mais le rôle
est un rôle très dramatique avec des
scènes cocasses et des scènes tendres et
des scènes très dures et en fait ce rôle
vous êtes là d'un bout à l'autre ai-je
pas quel âge avez vous
vous avez encore 16 ans vous avez tourné
un film quand vous aviez 16 ans et en
fait c'est une aventure tout à fait
heureuse qui s'est passé parce que ma à
savoir que vous aviez écrit au journal
première kish air qui annonça qu robin
davis chercher des jeunes pour son film
en la loi oui
et alors à ce moment-là j'ai envoyé une
photo pour comme un jeu en fait parce
que c'est une amie qui m'avait fait
remarquer il y avait cette annonce moi
même si je l'avais lu serait pas envoyé
parce que jean n'aura pas eu le courage
et donc j'en voyais ça comme ça et à la
suite de cela on m'a appelé pour faire
des essais et trois semaines après on
m'a appelé un jour un soir je lui dis
c'est ma mère me le dit et alors que je
pensais à autre chose je veux dire comme
maman m'a dit tiens il ya hors-la-loi
qui t'a appelé à la rigueur j'ai cherché
dans ma tête qu'est ce que c'était et à
ce moment là j'ai été faire des essais
et
j'aurais dû faire le film parents n'ont
pas voulu et donc je suis parti en
vacances parce que c'était la veille des
vacances et c'est là que j'ai reçu un
télégramme de véra belmont qui me
proposait premier rôle dans son film et
voilà et voilà mais c'est surtout c'est
il faut dire que cc charlott le rôle
principal du film via l'héroïne c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment l'histoire de
cette jeune fille parce que oui et c'est
cette histoire c'est donc une histoire
qui est un peu autobiographique véra
belmont a raconté pas mal de choses
qu'elle a vécu en tout cas à tout est
autobiographique c'est tout il la dit
quand on lui demande justement tout est
autobiographique
la seule différence c'est que la changer
un peu l'ordre c'est pas tout à fait
dans les événements way le personnage
que j'interprète ses personnages qu'elle
a rencontré qui travaillent
effectivement paris match qui qui évolue
aussi dans l'est dans les boîtes de nuit
parce que bon on en a parlé mais s'est
pas montré dans le dans l'extrait ça se
passe beaucoup dans dans les boîtes de
nuit de saint germain dans les années 50
il ya plein de lieux différents et ce
sont des lieux qu'elle a qu'elle a
traversé je dire qu'elle qu'elle connaît
très bien et vous êtes en train de
tourner un autre film maintenant on est
en train de tourner taxi boy un film
d'alain page avec le brasseur richard
berry voilà c'est tout ça paraît
maintenant très simple les choses sont
on commençait à tourner sa machine ses
liens avec un mouvement et ça s'est
passé très simplement non parce que très
souvent nous recevons du courrier de
deux jeunes filles au jeune garçon qui
dit ce qu'est ce que je dois faire pour
faire du cinéma oui alors je pense qu'il
est difficile pendant 20 ans
car si beaucoup de richesses et jeu et
je pense qu'il est difficile de dire eh
bien attendez que dans première en fasse
une petite annonce en disant que cas
metteur en scène cherche de jeunes du
jeune garçon et de jeune fille en tout
cas ça s'est très bien passé c'est ce
qui faisait ça a été vraiment un couteau
de la part de 2 verra pour charlotte
parce qu'elle a vu des centaines de
filles elle a fait vraiment beaucoup
d'essais et l a été
c'était un coup de foudre absolue pour
charlotte
[Musique]